welcome to the plane Lawrence web from
germany yet that's an English player so
you can guess from the name is a feed a
master i think i'm not mistaken a plate
he's got no additional info in now but i
think he played against my team won on
another board against a teammate of mine
ok we have a G Goren chigorin defense to
the Queens gambit by transposition with
nida 396 let's see yeah it's um now
that's surprising not it takes ok yeah I
don't mind to have an additional center
porn him but I'd like to get castled
first before I play something like a
form
yeah he might play five but I have 95
yeah this winds up on 95 Bishop b2
knight c6 should win upon they cannot
take on f3 I mean he can but at some
stategic Lee really do be dubious giving
me the excellent vision on a three yeah
so yeah well I cannot go age three
really because of Bishop g3s is some bit
uncomfortable Joe maybe get the Queen
into play
he goes in five yeah I thought that d5
now might be might be good answer it's
not so click why the night is going
where are you going with your light
that's crazy it has Devon is Graham I
was only thinking that this double
attack is quite good but yeah he just
hmm let's think just for a moment just
for a moment here hmm yeah okay and I
need to do I need to take him that
that's that's clear anyway but what now
if he takes here what is the best reply
yeah politics probably it wins it wins a
temple and then taking here yeah and it
should be yeah I'm thinking about taking
on b7 now so that I can simply keep this
pawn yeah yeah I'll give the exchange in
this is hardly a sacrifice as I have
this monster porn on b7
yeah but they have Fisher basics if
everything else fails I can always play
that but let's consider for a moment
queen here i'd like to get get a seven
low queen bee force probably also not
bad
or just just FF form yeah come on this
is a good one I hope the bishop comes to
g2 protecting this here maybe there was
some issue with the background camp but
this is certainly certainly good for the
wide okay i have this now securely
protected some may be asked his queen
where this is going to go
hmm well maybe just this one intending c
5 i'm 90 rock d 1 check no the only way
to lose this game is to some silly
tactic of course I could also just take
p6 it just wins in the end game look b4
c4 and now it's not see me it's not
seeing this even that's lucky luke t 1
wasn't simple trick yeah this is this
end camo Evers is of course completely
winning yeah
more than more than one good way to play
check
okay let's see how to how to best play
that is always going here now I can also
exchange I mean so a bit a bit too many
pawns
check yeah stalemate see only the only
thing that can can happen now time
warning check check check check check
check mate yeah that blunder disrupt e1
unbelievable to almost really the only
possible way to lose this is a new flag
c4 and here gaiam this is simple trick
yeah well the main point was that if I
was I think just unplayable I mean the
position is them is only a bit more
comfortable for white because of my
extra Center porn but oh D 5 D Phi
thesis is even easier it's even easier
winning a piece immediately I was only
thinking about this year with which
nevertheless also wins I mean this is
just more a bit more complicated the
pawn is just they're just far too strong
and T I am I mean 24 is the comp move
but even k taking is
it's just it's just winning flat flat
out right I don't I don't see how you
could defend that against the pawn which
is so nicely supported jump maybe this
one intending c5 you something like this
this is some probably relatively easy
win with their pond but still needs to
be needs to be played yeah this is
ridiculous of course at giving away the
game and now we are we have this dead
end game okay well White has multiple
multiple ways to win okay thanks for
watching